Hey everybody, this is Brent Dixon.
I'm an assistant scout master with Troop 192
in St Cloud, Florida.
This edition of the Scout Master Podcast
is very happily sponsored by backers like me.
And now to you, scout master.
Hey, Steve Buckman got in touch with me.
He said there's a little confusion
over knots in his troop
And they were trying to figure out what a sheep bend is
A sheep bend?
Well, Steve, I know there's not called a sheep shank
And you might be thinking of a sheet bend.
A sheet bend, right,
Not sheep with a P, but sheet with a T. OK,
Because there's no need to ever tie a sheep bend,
because that would be bad, bad.
Oh, come on,
I know there's better jokes out there.
Send them in, would you
Please.
Hey, this is podcast number 244..
Hey,
Hey.
Well, welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Hey, let's see.
Let's take a look in the mailbag and see
who got in touch over the past week.
We heard from Hugh.
He said: Clark, what's the name of the group
that does the cowbell version of the Happy Wanderer that
used to play on the podcast?
I want to use it for a roundtable on Thursday.
By the way, bring it back.
We need more cowbell.
Thanks for all you do.
Well, Hugh, I think this is exactly what you're
thinking of, right?
Oh my God.
Oh my God,
The group that does that is called the Salzburger Echo
And I'll have a link to where you can find that song.
And yeah, I used to play it a lot on the podcast
And I guess maybe it's time to bring it back a little bit.
So, you know, maybe we'll hear it every once in a while.
Thanks for getting in touch, Hugh.
I really appreciate it.
Andy Domert said I'm enjoying going back
through all the podcasts during my commute.
I believe you've got a couple of numbers mixed up
around number 30 or 31..
And I was looking for an index of the music
you use on the podcast.
Well, Andy, somewhere in the early part of the podcast
there we were between 25 and 35,. I missed a number
And I'll go and take a look at that on the archive
and see if I can get that sorted out.
But I know there's actually a missing number
somewhere in there.
So sorry for that confusion.
And you've given me another thing for the to-do list.
On most of the old podcasts on the post that contain those
on the blog, you'll find references to the music
that's in them.
But maybe I should come up with an easy to find list
that shows you where you can find
all of the different music I've used
over the past few years
And then, like Hugh, you can play it at the round table
so that you don't have to go to roundtables anymore,
because I mean, once they hear that right,
They're yeah. well. anyway,
I had several chances this week while I was working
at my desk to turn on the chat feature.
We had some great chats this past week
and I'm gonna try and do more of that in the future.
So keep an eye on the Twitter feed
and keep an eye on the Scoutmaster CG Facebook page
And I'll announce when that chat is going to be live.
Over this past week I chatted with Joe,
who's a Cubmaster in Burlington, Connecticut.
John Nelson in Westchester, Ohio.
he's an assistant Scoutmaster with Troop 947..
I also got the chat with Brad Findeson,
who is a Scoutmaster in 29 Palms, California,
in the California In-Line Empire Council.
I like the name of that council,
Dave Smiley from Santa Rosa, California.
Dave's a Scoutmaster.
He checked in on the chat.
Steve Cottrell is the Cubmaster of Pac 3623
in Central Michigan.
We got the chance to chat with Steve for a while.
We heard from Malaysia- BSA Troop 222 in Penang, Malaysia,
And Benny Coley is the Troop Committee Chairman there
for a troop of expats and missionaries
And he's working there with Scoutmaster Paul Hofmeier
and we're glad to talk to Benny on the chat.
Scout leader Shane is from Rockingham
in Western Australia.
He joined us to chat.
Dan White is in Birmingham, Alabama.
He is a Pat Committee Chair
and a Den Leader and Assistant Scoutmaster.
And finally, Mike Manager,
the Roundtable Commissioner from Atlanta, checked in too.
It was great to be able to chat with everybody.
Watch the Scoutmaster's CG Facebook page
and the Twitter feed
And I'll put the times of live chats
that we're able to manage in the future.
You'll be able to find them right there.
Then go to scoutmastercgcom and we'll chat
This week. I also heard from Doug Boyce
And Doug got in touch to say
I love listening to your podcasts and the articles.
I had a favor to ask you.
My son is working on Citizenship in the World Merit Badge
and he'd like to contact a Scout outside the United States
for one of the requirements.
So I posted that request on Facebook
and within a few minutes we had plenty of responses.
I had some folks get in touch via email
and now Doug's son has a number of resources
he can choose from to get in touch with people
for Citizenship in the World Merit Badge,
And I want to thank everybody who got in touch
with us and offered their help with that.
So, over on the blog, this week, Frank Maynard had this comment
on our last podcast where we addressed the question
of somebody who's worked on an Eagle Project
sitting on that Scout's Eagle Board of Review.
Frank had this to say:
having participated in a good many Eagle Scout projects
and having also later served on their boards of review,
I found it was a valuable insight
that I could use. that strengthened both my understanding
and the understanding of the candidate
of the process of developing leadership,
And we had a lot of enjoyable conversations.
So, if you don't already know,
Frank has a blog called Bob White Blather
and it's something that you should certainly check out,
especially if you're a committee chair
or serve on a troop committee somewhere.
Frank has a great deal of experience with that,
And I should say that Frank and I have collaborated
on a number of questions that I received
from a listener about Scouts and Money
And that'll be posted to the blog
this Wednesday,
So make sure to look for that.
This week on the blog
we also published a couple of chapters
of the new Scout Master series.
Patrick Provart commented about that.
I was a Scout Master from 1991 to 2002..
And it looks like I may have the chance to do it again
when my Weeblows son becomes a Scout.
This series is wonderful
to see what's changed and what hasn't.
Well, I'm glad you're enjoying it, Patrick.
John Nelson weighed in.
We as Scout Leaders have to teach our Scouts
how to play the game and what the rules are,
and then they can lead themselves.
And thanks, John,
Thanks for that.
That's one of the messages I certainly want to get across
in publishing that series.
And then finally, on the blog, yesterday, Sunday,
this week's installment of BP's blog
or Baden Powell's blog
talked about the retention of the older Scout
And I think what's really interesting
is a little bit of Scouting history there.
It was written in 1916,
within that first decade of Scouting,
as it was just kind of exploding all over the world.
And Baden Powell is musing about a senior Scout program
And I found it pretty interesting.
Check it out at scoutmastercgcom.
If you're a regular reader and a listener
and if the resources we've created have helped you.
you can return the favor
by becoming a scoutmastercgcom backer.
The funds we get from backers
go towards the expenses of producing
all of the stuff that we make- okay,
The podcasts, the blog posts, the videos-
And we use those funds to keep all of the resources
that we create accessible to Scouters all over the world.
Now, if you'd like to become a backer, it's very easy:
Go to scoutmastercgcom, right in the menu
at the top of the page.
You're gonna see a support link.
Follow that and you can choose any level of support.
Some of them entitle you to premiums,
like autographed copies of my books,
and we'll send them right out to you.
I'd like to take a moment to personally thank
Jeffrey Crump, who became a backer since our last podcast,
And if you go to scoutmastercgcom this week,
just like Jeff did, and become a backer,
I'll be sure to thank you personally on our next podcast.
Well, in this 244th podcast,
I've got some thoughts and Scout Mastership
in seven minutes or less, about talking to Scouts
and listening to their answers,
And then we've got some email questions to answer,
and that is going to take up
the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
Master'ship in seven minutes or less.
It's a simple thought. but I want you to talk to your Scouts
and not talk down to them, not give them orders,
but I want you to sit and talk to them,
And I know that a lot of you already do this.
but a lot of times, some of my first advice
on questions I receive
is: well, have you asked the Scouts how they feel about that?
We'll find that they have lots of answers if we ask
and if we listen carefully. and to get good at listening,
I think the first step is looking at our own attitudes
and our understanding of the role that we play.
Listening to young people requires
that we know something in their lives
and the challenges and changes that they're working through,
And we have to cultivate that understanding.
We have to be intentionally compassionate,
and compassion comes from understanding.
Now, a lot of times,
Scouts who don't have good relationship skills-
and I would say probably especially men,
because I are one right-
We use aggression and rigid attitudes
to compensate for a whole range of things,
And usually it's our own inadequacies and fears.
An aggressive or kind of senselessly rigid attitude
will give you short-term control.
You'll be able to control your Scouts
and you'll be able to control everything around you right,
But that's it.
You're not gonna get much else.
I'm a big, imposing man.
I'm six foot one.
I have a very healthy avert du pois.
I have a uniform and a big hat.
I've got a big beard.
I've got a deep voice.
I can stand in the middle of a room of Scouts
and I can use my physical stature and my loud voice
to get attention and get them to do what I want them to do,
But that gives no lasting effect.
I haven't achieved anything but compliance.
Our mission is so much bigger than that, isn't it?
We're on a mission to change lives
and we don't get much change or growth
through compliance to our aggressive or rigid attitudes.
And you can apply an aggressive or a rigid attitude
to have a very smooth running, high-attieving troop
without any real personal growth or development
on the part of individual Scouts.
And that's why I think it's very, very important
that you talk to your Scouts
and you learn to listen with a little humility,
And we just may begin to see what they need
and how we can help them build on their understanding
of the Scout Oath and Law.
Given the opportunity to offer their ideas and solutions
to problems or conundrums that we're running across
Scouts begin to call on those developing inner strengths.
that is our main aim to develop.
As we move along, we begin to see the Scouting Spirit
in an individual Scout's heart is really the source. okay,
And what I mean by that is we may think that our program
or our prowess or our traditions
or our practices are the source. they're not.
It's a big mistake, and it's one that is as big
as it is common.
We can't impose the Spirit of Scouting
and all the good that flows from that on a Scout.
It's already there, waiting for our ears,
waiting for us to listen
and waiting for us to help our Scouts discover.
Alls we have to do is talk to them
and learn to listen to what they have to say.
If you'll take the time to do that- and, like I said,
do that with compassion and humility.
listen to what your Scouts have to say-
the list of problems and challenges
begins to grow a lot smaller.
My name
Email, that is folks,
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
I heard from Scoutmaster Jim Hu,
who is with Troop 309 in Morton, Illinois,
And he wrote in to ask this:
how do you handle a Scout who has earned
the first aid Marriott badge
at one of those Marriott badge fairs
and now wants you to sign off
on the Tenderfoot second class
and first class first aid requirements.
Well, Jim, fairly simple answer.
I'd sign off the requirements
the same way I would for any other Scout.
And if a Scout has first aid Marriott badge,
demonstrating those first aid requirements
would be really simple
and probably wouldn't take all that long.
Now if they complained to me,
or their parent complained to me,
that they had already done that,
I would show them this from the guide to advancement.
Here we are in the guide to advancement folks,
and you know about the numbers, right
Pencil's ready. here we go
In section 4.2.3.6,
titled Fulfilling More than One Wireman
with a Single Activity,
And so let me read this to you.
From time to time
it may be appropriate for a Scout to apply
what he has done to meet one requirement
toward the completion of another.
in deciding whether to allow this,
unit leaders or Marriott badge counselors
should consider the following:
When, for all practical purposes,
two requirements match up exactly
and have the same basic intent-
for example, camping nights for the second class
and first class ranks and for the camping Marriott badge-
it is appropriate and permissible,
unless it is stated otherwise in the requirements
to use those matching activities
for both ranks and the Marriott badge,
Where matching requirements are oriented towards safety,
such as those related to first aid or CPR,
the person signing off the requirements
should be satisfied that the Scout remembers
what he learned from the previous experience,
And I think that says it all, doesn't it?
So not only in the instance that you stated, Jim,
there are requirements that can be fulfilled
within a single activity.
I think that the guide to advancement
is very clear on this,
especially where matching requirements
are oriented towards safety.
We wanna make sure that the Scout remembers
what he had learned from the previous experience.
Heard from Bill Chapman.
he says: I'm a relatively new Scout master
and our troop had a history of focusing on advancement,
with most troop meetings in a classroom
and the instruction by the Scout master
or other adult instructor.
We combined three small troops
and we're trying to use the patrol method
to have a scout led troop.
In the beginning I spent a lot of time
trying to train our senior patrol leader
to run troop meetings and camp outs
and to get our patrol leaders council up to speed.
But I did not grow up in Scouting
and I don't have enough Scouting skills
and experience to really train them. well,
I have an assistant Scout master and no Scouting,
but I worry about us directing the program too much.
How do we train our senior patrol leader
to run the patrol leaders council
and provide a good quality program
without taking over and running it ourselves?
Well, Bill, that is a great question.
How do you train the senior patrol leader
to run the patrol leaders council
and provide a good quality program
without taking it over and running it ourselves?
So let's pay attention to two key things
that you said in asking that question.
I'm gonna pick out two terms:
One is training and the other is good quality program.
So let's begin with that first.
What is a good quality program?
And you're gonna determine that very subjectively, right,
Every parent somewhere has a little drawing
or a little lopsided clay statue
or something that their child created and gave them,
And I've used this as an illustration before.
but you'll remember, right,
That little statue or that little drawing
is not going to be in a national museum
or the critics aren't gonna be writing about it,
but to you it's priceless
And we need to look at what our scouts are doing
and the quality of our program
from precisely that perspective.
When you start to see just how much scouting
is actually going on in the midst of all the chaos
and things that look kind of disjointed,
well, you begin to get the idea-
And we talk about this a lot-
because scouting is unique
and it requires a unique perspective
on the part of the adults involved.
I'll bet that there's a lot more quality
in what your scouts are doing than your first thought.
Now, the other term that I wanted to take a little time
to talk about was training,
And I would probably prefer, for the most part,
that scouts forgot what they know
about training youth leaders,
because we have a tradition of session
and event-based training
that I don't think works very well,
Not because I think that the sessions
and the event-based training are totally ineffective
or they don't have any good content to them,
but because of the attitude
with which most scouts regard them.
Hey, you've been to training,
you know what to do. now I'm all done. here we go.
But the difficulty is is there's no way
you can train a person to be a leader.
The only way you become a leader is by leading right,
Not by being trained to be a leader.
you have to actually start leading,
and that's what you're gonna do with your scouts.
Be mindful that every contact you have
with your senior patrol leader
and your patrol leaders council
is an opportunity for developing youth leadership.
Go slowly and incrementally
and ask lots and lots of questions
designed to help them discover things
and build on it a little at a time.
You say you don't have a whole lot of experience
with scouting. well, you know what
You're going to learn right along with them
and if you're humble enough to say that to them,
they're gonna work right along with you
and you're gonna develop your skills as a scout master
as they develop their skills as youth leaders.
If you're doing a restart,
if you're kind of starting from scratch,
this is gonna work really well.
You may first have to model some of the things
for the scouts.
You may need to show the senior patrol leader
how to be a senior patrol leader.
You may need to show patrol leaders how to be patrol leaders,
but then you can hand it off to them as they catch on.
The biggest mistake we make, I think, sometimes
in working with youth leaders
is we think we can sit down
and in one sitting, explain everything to them
and they got it and we're done from there.
but it never really works that way.
Don't overload them, don't over instruct.
Give them one or two things to work on at a time.
let them try them out,
maybe even show them how it works by doing it yourself
and then let them at it.
As time goes by they'll begin to pick up on things
and they'll begin to model the behavior
and skills of leadership for the new scouts
that joined the troop.
Then you have this kind of self perpetuating model right.
But our role in the process is mentors
and questioners. continually developing youth leadership
never stops.
I got this question.
I don't concur with the way my scout master runs
leadership elections.
He says anyone should be eligible
to be elected senior patrol leader.
I say we should limit the eligibility
for senior patrol leader and other important positions
for the scouts who are on their way to star
and life ranks and at least 15 years old.
Well, you know I understand your concern,
but I'm gonna say I agree with your scout master.
Any scout ought to be able to put themselves forward
to be elected the senior patrol leader.
If we reserve that only for scouts who needed a position
of responsibility for advancement,
or we thought we're qualified
or we wanted only older scouts running for that position,
we're denying the chance to a younger,
perhaps more talented and mature scout,
or a scout is otherwise a good leader
but really isn't interested in advancing in rank.
David wrote to me and said I'm looking for some guidance
on high adventure patrols.
Eventually our scouts want to go on high adventure tracks
and we've been breaking up existing patrols
and creating high adventure patrols
that train and prepare for the track.
This has the side effect of abandoning boys in the old patrol
that aren't interested in the high adventure track
and I believe it hurts the patrol method.
I'm looking for advice on how others have dealt with this.
David, I really don't see much practical use
in resetting patrols around a high adventure trip.
In my experience, when we've had a high adventure trip
scheduled, which we do every single summer,
the guys who are gonna form that crew
aren't preparing for and training during troop meetings
or camping trips for the high adventure trip.
They're following a separate schedule of things like that.
For the most part, these scouts are mostly
our troops' youth leadership, so it wouldn't work
to have them distracted from doing that during troop time.
So I think that's a reasonably simple solution.
You don't need to reset the troops patrols.
You need a separate schedule
for the guys who are going on high adventure.
Heard from Craig Dixon, who is the scout master
troop 682 in Poe, California.
One of my scouts ran for senior patrol leader two times
and he wasn't elected either time.
I'm quite sure he's disappointed.
What would you say to him
And do you have any suggestions for how I
or the new senior patrol leader can keep him involved
and maybe take advantage of his skills?
Well, Craig, let's talk to the scout.
Let's ask if he's disappointed-
Maybe he is, maybe he isn't-
And how he's coping with that. if he is disappointed,
You probably have a story of disappointment
from somewhere in your life
and how you coped and you can work through that with him.
I would tell him how valuable a resource he is as a leader
and that you would like to know exactly
how he'd like to serve his fellow scouts.
Ask him what he wants to do, what kind of work he enjoys,
and then work out how you're gonna make that happen for them.
Maybe it's something like scribe or quarter master,
instructor or dent chief,
And if those are positions of responsibility,
don't appeal to him. develop one that fits.
If he's 15 or 16 years old,
you can do what I've done many times,
and that is have the senior patrol leader
appoint that person to be a junior assistant scout master,
who then can take on whatever general
or specific responsibilities interest them.
A first class or star scout can fulfill
a tenure position of responsibility for star or life
by completing what's called a scout master
assigned leadership project,
And I've used that on many occasions as well.
where I'll sit down with a scout,
we'll define the project,
we'll define the parameters of a project,
the expectations of exactly what he'll be doing,
and we've done that successfully many, many times.
Hey, if you have a question that you could use
a little help with, you can get in touch
and you're gonna learn how to do that in just a moment.
["Squad Master Podcast"].
Hey, thanks for listening to this 244th edition
of the Scout Master Podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch.
First of all, go to the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and while you're there, you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog by email.
You can join 4,000 other mobile scouters
who have the Scout Master CG app on their mobile devices,
and the app is available on Google Play
and in the iTunes app store.
You can experience all the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media outlets
as many others do.
Join the 7,000 folks who like Scout Master Blog
on Facebook. tweet along with the chorus
of 1,100 tweeters on Twitter.
pin the pultritudinous pictures proffered publicly
with 1,800 other prolific pinners on Pinterest.
watch us at Scout Master CG on YouTube
or join the 400 odd folks who form
the exclusive Scout Master CG circle on Google+.
Wait a minute. you tell me you're not amused
with the vast panorama of social media
You can't face Facebook. Twitter makes you better.
you have no interest in Pinterest.
You don't put the you in YouTube.
Oh, if you're a minus when it comes to Google+,
that's all right. Bunky,
Do this for me. zoom into the late 90s
and fire off an email.
You can get in touch with me
at clark at scoutmastercgcom.
It's C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom.
And though you've heard it 244 times,
I must repeat: the Scout Master Blog
and the Scout Master Podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America
or any other Scouting Organization for that matter.
They all have much better things to do
with their time. of course,
It's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to Scout Leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
let's hear from our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Pelton.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.